I know you don't want to much fun man
hey everybody thanks for watching
riffing with Griffin if you want to see
me live make sure you go to Eric Griffin
com
I'm coming to the Dayton funny bone I'm
coming to the Ontario improv I'm gonna
be at the Motor City comedy festival in
Detroit so make sure you go to Eric
Griffin I got calm to check all that
stuff out guys I really appreciate all
your support and I also want to say
thanks to my bookie for supporting RIF
and with Griffin my book he has better
bonuses and more prop bets than any
other sports book period this year
they're hosting the first online
handicapping super contest first place
is guaranteed to win at least $100,000
and it only costs $100 to enter visit my
bookie online today and use the promo
code riffin when creating your account
to claim your bonuses now back to the
podcast I mean you see do the whole the
whole hour like that well I mean after
like five minutes you everybody be like
oh this is cute but ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the podcast
one of my good friends known you for
such a long time
from mental and many things in my career
you don't even realize but get up for
the very funny in town to mister Maz
Jobrani woohoo yeah you should get like
one person as your live studio audience
right there I could just get part of my
patreon you come over and you can sit in
my tiny little room live podcast you
know there's some people that would love
that would probably do it in my living
room sometime I'll be like you know if
you're like if you're like a gold member
on my patreon you can like you know you
can come in my living room as I record
bro you have got some probably hardcore
fans everybody does dying to do that you
know somebody's I've been getting some
really nice messages from people about
the podcast but it's like we're so used
to like being funny or like that's what
we think is the what do you call it is
the is the point of why people listen
right right but actually the things that
they they mentioned have nothing to do
with being funny well pocket first of
all you don't know how you affect other
people until Ian they come up to you at
a show or something and they go whatever
I was down I was you know is sick
whatever it is you help me through it
but also podcast I think have helped
this Renaissance of comedy I know making
us stay relevant but also like you
you're finding fans of yours that are
interested in what you have to say and
then they come into your live show and
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah but I
know what you're saying by how you touch
people's lives because I got been
talking a lot I'm on stage even on stage
about I think you know I'm dealing with
my mom and the dementia right you know
and it's amazing how many people come up
to me and just like oh you're talking
about my mom all this is what I did and
then they have they give me a little
some information it's like like this
personal conversation you're having with
people and so you know it's pretty cool
you know I just think the whole
podcasting thing is like alright we'll
see we'll see where it goes
well you know I think we are hyperedge
it might it might do I sound a little
echoey to you am i okay you know it's
fine it's gonna be fine it's just
because of the it's this guy yeah but
we're good don't worry about it but I
think I think that you just like I think
we over scrutinize what we're saying
sometimes we go I don't know if that's
funny I don't this is right on if
there's appropriate but but then once
you just start talking because
ultimately it's about having a point of
view right yeah and you have a point of
view and you realize there's a lot
people who have that point of view or
are intrigued by that point of view or
even want to just argue with you about
the point of view whatever it is so it's
just like just express yourself yeah
yeah so many times up I've got a scene a
movie and I've been like what a great
movie but going yeah they really they
didn't really it kept it very simple
yeah yeah yeah wasn't over the top at
all it was just right there and I go god
that's just an just telling a story yeah
I know I know but it's like I don't know
I mean it's like it's like we've been in
the business so long you know watching
it transform into something else has
just been like you know that's that's
the fun part right that's what we keep
doing it because why else what why else
will we keep doing it well you gotta
adapt no matter what I think but
somebody was asking me the other day to
go you know you've done you've written a
book you don't stand up in the movies
but like how did how do you go between
all of them I go it's just all
storytelling yeah basically it's all
story - and a lot of times you're
repeating a lot of the stories or you
have new stories in your life that you
bring to whatever it is and that's what
this is we just sit here and talk and
this might spark an idea where you go
I'm gonna go do that on stage right
right right right I think that's why we
do we do it because I think we like to
tell stories yeah yeah hear ourselves
talk to hear these like oh yeah it
sounds great it's fantastic I'm
constantly casting myself in animation
movies and like just any audition you go
to or in your heart you see yeah I think
to yourself like why am I not why didn't
I go out for that well maybe if you did
go out for it somebody else got it
you're like why didn't I get that
actually or you're sitting there going
like like a lot of times I'll go home
don't be like why doesn't this casting
director know like I could nail this
yeah
why didn't it like oh you see something
he'd be like I love forget about I was
just watching veep on all those
beautiful I loved it that's a great show
I was like why wasn't I on this show I
was like this could those people said
the same thing and they got it by the
way by the way I also like check myself
I go I would not ever say that I'd be
better than because they're all so great
in those par so good I'm like everybody
nails apart so going like I just wish
they could have written one other part
yeah there's one other guy you know
whatever he is the he's the water
delivery guy yeah that's all you know so
you've been you
oh yeah I know it does sound like we're
echoing or something yeah yeah I'm not
sure if it's um I don't know what it but
it's gonna be fine I trust you okay good
yeah it's gonna be fine just don't call
me and be like can you come back and
then I'll give you a script you say all
of this the same way you said it but
you've been in a lot of parts but like
as a not what do you tell you so because
I was making fun of you on the phone I
was like I don't thing I was like yeah
you Arabs are always late yeah we're all
very sensitive to that kind of [ __ ] no
man it's all good listen I always like I
use the term Middle Eastern or like at
least an American or Iranian America
what-have-you but yeah I've done a lot
of those parts with the accent with the
character and continue to go out on them
sometimes and I'm and all honestly like
I'm at the point where I'm kind of
rolling my eyes going like oh come on
still yeah can I just can I just be this
guy and it was like when the cops shoot
a young black kid you're like you're
what you need to shoot a white young
white dude come on yes you were doing
those up but you know what just real
quick what in your words what is the
difference between like why is it why is
there a distinction in your words
between what if you call it Arab Middle
Eastern yeah give it to me so it says
it's an ethnic background so Arabs come
so Arabs are you know that encompasses
certain countries in the Middle East so
the Arabs are like you know the Saudis
and the and you've got your Qataris and
your these are the Gulf Arabs Emiratis
that's all the Gulf Arabs and you've got
like your African Arabs which the
Egyptians and the Tunisians just still
considered Arab yeah because there's now
now even within those countries there is
like Arabs and then there's the Berbers
for examiner Morocco has like the
Berbers that aren't the Arabs or like or
if you talk to put your hand on this
side if you say like I said this is to
this lady I was doing a show and I was
like yo Lebanese you guys like you guys
are Arab she's like we're not Arab but a
Lebanese so they come from like
Phoenicians I mean there's all kinds of
like if you if you go down the line now
Iran Ian's the word Iran actually comes
from the word Aryan
are from like weird we're evolved from
the caucus mountains with the original
Aryans like we're from were the white
people of that were white people we are
the we are the original white people and
it's funny cuz I just want you guys are
so bougie we have fair boozy I did a I
did a whole bit about it and my stand-up
years ago and somebody like email me go
like well you know the word Aryan
carries a lot of negative connotations I
know I'm just talking about like if you
trace it back thousands and thousands of
years that's what we're from the
Iranians the original or one of the
original religions of Iran was a Rast
rien ism which is the first monotheistic
religion and it was not Islam so then
the Arabs invaded Iran and Islam came to
Iran in the I don't know 1500s 1400
whatever so then when you say so then
it's only people from Iran that don't
like being called Arab whether if you
called an Afghan an Arab I'm sure they
say no we're Afghan we're not Arabs so
it's not a catch Arab it's not a
catch-all for like ever like anglo-saxon
no no Arab is what I thought yeah it's a
regional Arab is a regional thing and
there's like a handful of countries
whether it's Jordan or so Arab is like
saying American you kind of like that
but also within the Arabs they have
different countries and they have also
their own like again a Lebanese would be
like well no the Saudis are the real
Arabs we're not like because they're
Gulf they're a Gulf Arab so basically
when you say Arab though like in America
now let's go to America uh-huh when a
lot of Iranians would be like but why
are you like defending the Muslim Arabs
and I'm like because if you go to
airport you know at the airport security
we're all brown and we're all Mohammed
yeah so we're all gonna be so like I
feel like in America we have come to
kind of not always but sometimes
somewhat consolidate because that's how
that's how Trump America or or I should
say any redneck might see us they might
be like oh they're all the same like I
just like in the same way everybody's
Mexican everybody's Mexico cries max you
speak Spanish you're Mexican
you're like you know I'm actually
Colombia you're like
what's weird about this they'll help how
we're talking about it just feels like
that's why the region doesn't get along
all these little distinctions well the
point is no but the point is the region
art is different countries see the
problem is here's the bigger problem
we're supposed to assume that just
because everybody's an Arab or looks the
same they should get along and they just
don't exactly and also I think the
problem we have is living in America is
we're so far from the rest of the world
we got Canada North Mexico South but
we're really American centric when it
comes to our world knowledge well you
know what you know I get mad like you
hear people Europeans will be like oh
yeah America I only speak America right
you know why because the United States
is bigger than all of your countries put
together well so we don't meet what I'm
saying is like the United States was
just California yeah and then Mexican in
Nevada yeah and all these places were a
different country yeah that's what we
speak those languages a Mitsubishi ylim
and spent a semester going by the way
it's good it's great to know American
history but by the way there's other
countries then I think sometimes in our
minds it wouldn't have to take us
attacking a country for us to learn
about that country and here we go oh
it's true but but also like for example
I'll tell you for me like I grew I was
born in Iran grew up in America and I
didn't really leave America from the
moment I got here when I was six years
old and ever since we didn't leave until
I was in college and I went to Italy to
study abroad and while I was in Italy
they were like talking about America's
involvement in World War two in Italy
and stuff and it opened my eyes was like
oh my god like there's a lot of history
can be told from many different points
of view it's his story exactly and so
but but that's why but that's why what
I'm saying is when it comes to
distinguishing the Middle East like when
you hear people go like who's America
goddamnit if you don't I could go back
to your country will bomb all the Arabs
but you go wait a minute those countries
don't all necessarily get along they're
different countries like it's like
saying for example you know if you go to
South America you've got Brazil you got
our chanting you got Chile got all these
countries next was you doesn't mean they
get a matter of fact usually neighbors
hate each other what I'm saying
right so we were fortunate we only have
two neighborhoods
exactly and we assume so we assumed that
they're all the same thing they're not
all the same thing as a matter of fact
again going back to some historical
stuff like one of the things that blows
my mind with when we went to war with
Iraq was America at the time the Bush
administration was saying that you know
public enemy number one is Iran Iran's
the biggest threat to world peace
buh-ba-ba-bah but Iraq was Iran's
neighbor was actually enemies with Iran
and Saddam Hussein was kind of helping
keep Iran in check because in Iraq now
this is where it gets a little
complicated is that you know how we have
Catholics so we got Protestants and Iraq
was a country with a minority of Sunnis
so Saddam was Sunni Muslim but they were
ruling a country that was a majority of
Shiites and Iran is Shiite so when we
got rid of Saddam we basically played
into the hands of Iran because Iran all
of a sudden goes oh now we got now we
got more influence in Iraq so what I'm
trying to get at is even at that highest
of levels like when we were going to war
I was like I can't I can't believe that
no expert has come in or I can't believe
the Dick Cheney in those guys wouldn't
know that they're actually helping Iran
by getting rid of Saddam Hussein so
because that was the plan you know yeah
it's just cause boy I don't know world
politics we don't we don't but that's
what I'm saying so it does help us a
little bit to know a little bit about
everywhere I just got I just did a tour
in Judaism chosen in Asia I did I did
Singapore and I did Jakarta and it was
amazing cuz I go I don't know much about
these places at all yeah and I'm there
for example random random random were in
some like little mall in Singapore and
there's this sign explaining kind of how
this mall was built and when you go
there and Singapore there's something
that says bu GI and I go that's bougie
they go no that's boogie and boogie were
like the natives of that place and it
talks about the word boogie man comes
from that oh wow when the Europeans were
fighting these natives in Singapore and
they were savvy
and they were called the boogeyman I go
what I go how is that boogeyman was a
scary dude
no boogeyman comes from Singapore the
Asian I mean that's what I'm saying it
just blows my mind that I'm like wow
okay so bringing this back full circle
is like so here you are like in
Hollywood you started at The Comedy
Store yeah you were one of those guys um
ed what was the other guy Aaron and
Aaron yes were all around that same time
yeah so what happened was first of all I
remember you and I met years ago before
you had kind of taken a little
sabbatical we met we were performing a
strip club oh my god that's the first
time I met you remember there was no
markers no micro microphone goes out
yeah so that was when I was taking the
Judy Carter comedy stand-up comedy class
she had said like go and perform as much
as you can anywhere anywhere so this
dude Bobby [ __ ] Bobby [ __ ] the
dude that can get a show anywhere you
know last like three shows yeah and
those people figure out they're getting
I remember he had a show at a rib joint
I believe on Sunset yeah he got the
owner to give the comics free ribs
hilarious lasted two to two nights of
that show nice guy figured out like I'm
just giving away free food yeah yeah
yeah
so Bobby had that room so somehow I
found out about it an idea was you get
five dollars for every audience member
you bring and it was one of the first
times I was actually doing my set in
front of an audience really yeah because
I was I was nervous so I was like I was
like listen I told of handful of friends
I go listen don't tell anybody but of
course they told everybody yeah so I had
31 people show up oh good for you and
that night there was like 35 total
audience member right
so it was like stripper comic stripper
comic which is ridiculous well no what
happened was if you recall first of all
because I brought so many people Bobby
put me up last so all my friends had to
watch all this shitty comedy no offense
but we were all sitting and at one place
it was all stand-up horrible strippers
well well what happened was he when I
got there he goes listen um I got some
good news bad news good news this show
is on bad news is the owners of clubs
sold the club last night
and they took the mic I go wait a minute
why would a strip club owner the only
thing it took was the mic yeah what is
that that's expensive that mic was yes
is it but the show must go on so my mic
drop no I'm taking the mic with me but
it was funny was there was a guy named
Jeremy I forget his last name Jeremy
something he was another guy who he kind
of reminded me a little bit of Elliott
Gould or something I know who you're
talking about
yes so he was so if you recall it was a
strip club community stripper comedian
it was it was it was side room in a
strip club strip strippers are stripping
in the main room we're in the side room
we're doing our show without a mic
Jeremy's on stage at a certain point
like gangbanger looking dude walks in
with a stripper coz like he was like
let's go talk so he brought her there so
he's sitting there talking to her in the
middle of Jeremy set and Jeremy was like
hey excuse me I'm gonna show up here and
the guy was like we'll keep doing it
then or whatever it was he was very
threatening and everybody looked her
like oh we about to be shot it was like
a disaster how the good old days our
comedy days bro wow that's the first
time we met and it was funny because I
got paid $155 at night oh you bastard he
won people but the funny thing is some
of the people that came to my show that
night have never come back to another
show cuz I think they had such a bad
experience but those are the days when
you had to invite people you did a lot
of bringer shows I hate those yeah so
those will bring us and then so what
happens is then I become a regular at
The Comedy Store and when I become a
rigger the comic store I was her only
middle-eastern comedian on the on the on
the bill so she'd be putting me up late
and I'd be going up and I was I was a
relatively clean comedian and like
trying to do some political stuff but
I'd be following like Joe Diaz Brian
Holtzman right I don't like that's why I
bonded with Joe Diaz the most I was like
why did she put me up now he's like
broke she's got plans for you bro you
know she's got Mitch he's got plans I'm
like I don't know what those plans are
but I'm I'm following Eddie Griffin at
145 I mean so ever he just did 45
minutes 45 about an hour 15 minutes said
I was crazy yeah so back then so that
was that
and at the time my buddies my closest
buddies were like Sam Tripoli Bret Ernst
and I was trying to help get those guys
in because I was in now and I'm trying
to get them in a little bit it's
interesting and then I get a call from
Duncan Duncan Trussell who was the
Booker at the club at the time just
crazy and he goes listen Mitzi Mitzi
just was watching CNN and there was the
latest uprising with the Palestinians
against the Israelis this was in the
year 2000 and he goes she feels like
there's gonna be a need for a positive
voice of Muslims and Arabs and all these
sinners she had she knew in the near
future this before September 11 yeah and
she goes she wants to put together a
show the same way she used to do like
black night and Latino night she goes
she wants to do a Middle East and I he
goes do you know any other Middle
Eastern comedians and at the time she
had seen Ahmed cuz I'm Ed was doing
dublin's with Jay Davis right and this
was right after that was right after
they used to do cues billiard because
that's really where I met Jay in a met
right so then when we've cues to Dublin
it was so hot there that Pauly Shore
told Jay Davis why don't you bring a
night to the comic store so Jay started
doing Rockstar comedy at them in the
main room and that's where I'm ed was
performing when Mitzi saw Ahmed so Mitzi
brought I meant to the table I'd met
Ahmed but but still like she brought him
to the table I had seen Aron Kader one
time at the haha cafe and I just
overheard him saying I'm Palestinian and
Mormon so when Duncan called me he goes
do you know anybody else I go there's a
guy named Aaron I saw him there great
guy I don't know we were trying to put a
team together oh did you by the way like
when it comes to like black comedians
there's a bunch of um Latinos a bunch of
back then
Middle Eastern Europe I was about to say
you don't know there's a lot there's not
a lot of Arab comics until you're
looking for Eric on absolutely I was
like who do we have we had nobody so
then that's when I was like I called up
Sam Tripoli I go listen your last name
is Tripoli Tripoli as the capital of
Libya you gotta be something are you
Libyan he goes well I'm half Armenian I
go I think that works
I call it Duncan Duncan was friends with
Tripoli too and Tripoli had audition in
front of me a few times and not gotten
in Oh when she found out that he's half
Armenian in
and and all you had to do was like just
do a couple of Harry being Harry jokes
at the top of your set and then do you
arrest your set right so we got him in
that way and then she put the show
together and called it the Arabian
Nights and it was anybody who was middle
Easterner or Arab yeah or brown so she
had a guy this Indian dude showed out up
out of nowhere it was on the show and
I'm like that's not really me at least
simplify what they go uh-huh and then he
had lemare was this girl who would do
like like she would do like a belly like
a funny belly dance was it she white
girl you know belly dancer it was a
crazy crazy [ __ ] and I remember having a
conversation with I met at the beginning
going who is gonna come see our show
like there's no audience for us and they
were like no let's go for it so we all
reached out to like the Persian student
group Arab student group Muslim student
group pockets you name it we were
calling UCLA Josie and I'm sure they
showed a pro first time we did the show
Mitzi put us in the main room now our
accomplice was like 150 CEO still though
it was full still though and I was like
holy [ __ ] then I was like those
[ __ ] show up for you guys
here's the problem though the problem is
again going back to what we're saying
all the other communities got like show
too
you can have a whole new lineup we
couldn't we were like with the same guys
so they're coming back six months later
and we're doing the same [ __ ] I'm like
and then actually was funny because then
also with Brad Ernst who was another guy
we were running with that had nothing to
do with the Middle Eastern side but but
we were I was trying to help get bread
in we were all like we're all trying to
get him in and one night Mitsy had some
show she you know me room show she put
us all on and Bret was on there too but
I'm sorry yeah Bret was supposed to be I
think it was Jay Davis's night or some
so he could book people from outside so
then Mitzi's there and Mitzi was
watching me closely like she would be
like she would like to watch me like she
was very nice to me and I was like
whatever I was like whew down the line I
wasn't supposed to go up yet and someone
comes over and they go hey Maz Mitch he
wants you to go up next and I go ah man
I really wanted her to see Brett I go
I'll tell you what tell her you can't
find me so Brett can go up so I so then
he goes back goes can't find so Brett
went up I had a great set and became
regular boom-boom I was like that's
fantastic I said I would uh good for you
man yeah man that's what you gotta do
that's just Lotte I love to hear that
because it's like you know see I wasn't
I at the time see I should have been
with you guys yeah you left for a while
yeah I left for a long one but that's
the time it was like you know I'm a med
had me over at like I said we were what
are the cues billiard and in Pasadena
yeah and then it's like but then right
when the Dublin's thing started I was
out and then I came back in right when
the Dublin's thing ended right like him
Mitchell had a thing whatever happened
and that just broke that's right mister
that's when I got back into yeah yeah so
then it wasn't till you know I don't
remember god I don't even remember like
they're like didn't even I'm just around
no I remember you showing up again I was
like where have you been man yeah but
you hit the grab it it was funny because
similar like I had to catch up that's
why I was but that's why you came in so
fast it so hard because it was similar
to like when I wanted to do stand-up
when I was a kid I saw Eddie Murphy me
too so I was like I want to be half the
reason why I did it too and so having
immigrant parents I would tell them I
want to do this and they would say hell
no after you go to law school and so
what was funny was in in high school I
tried to do a little bit and I chickened
out and in college I did a little bit
and I didn't know what to do with this I
was in my early 20s and I just let it go
cuz I was like I gotta go move on with
my life and so wasn't I was 26 when I
when I got into that stand-up comedy
class but because I've been doing plays
I was confident being on stage and I had
so much built-up that first class that I
took the whole point was that they're
gonna help us write five minutes and we
were gonna perform at the last lesson
you know the last class we got to
perform at The Improv in front of a
bunch of people my class I got to
perform at The Comedy Store well that's
what I'm saying so I had so much built
up that by the time we were done in
those six weeks I had like 10 minutes 15
minutes I was like way to go and I think
is the same thing for you you were ready
to go yeah it's just it's just one of
those things man that I was like I felt
like I always I let the regret that I
built drive me to keep going that's all
that it was whose classes you take I
took sandy shores okay yeah
but you were after Sebastian Sebastian -
Sammis it was after Sebastian I didn't
meet like I said and meet all these
people until like going to like after a
med tried to get me in at economy store
admits he didn't even say a word to me
it wasn't no on the raw she was sitting
there I walked over I'm talking about
like like ice queen like looking at this
[ __ ] yeah and so then I was like
she passed Jay Davis yeah yeah yeah
serious it's crazy it drives you nuts
because exactly we just said you go wait
a minute I'm better than that guy I I
helped I helped godfrey get an audition
and I was like hey are you in he's like
no man yeah I was a Godfrey it took a
year it took like a year of like then it
was then it became between me and Tommy
right and it was like Connor I was like
you know I'm doing these you know these
like dumb like a family friend spot
whatever it was and then a lot of people
it's like just sort of vouching for me
like yeah it's like I'd be standing the
outside in economy's Torrance and Tommy
walk by whoever I was talking to would
be like do you know we were Griffon and
then I would look at him like dude I
didn't tell them to say that so he
eventually got me a showcase in the main
room right you know I'm one of Vargas
and Kathy's show right and that's one
towards the end of bringing Mitchie to
the comedy store I honestly believe I
think I was one of the last people that
she actually passed yeah yeah you know
she walked through the hallway yeah my
said and she was like you was funny and
that's it only word she's ever said yeah
you know yeah yeah so but anyways so
then then then I just did it's like
whatever you know you know and then it
was like you know I you know like I met
had remembered me from like doing cues
so he was like mister like okay let's go
do stuff then we do you know I started
doing shows and then he took me with you
guys today I show you know when we went
to the Middle East yeah so that happens
so so that was like you know that's like
over ten years ago it's crazy dude it's
funny because all those all those years
to me seemed like so many years but I
remember like again like when we first
started at the store it was me Brett
Sebastian and Sam were hanging together
yeah that was the crew that was a crew
and and I remember one it was a new year
we went like on New Year's Eve we all
went to some party and Brett's
I guess ex-girlfriend Denise had a
picture and she put like this thing he
said you know the four horsemen or
whatever the apocalypse and so we all
got that picture and we were all in it
but it feels like it was a lot more time
spent but it was probably like a year or
two time period but we were there every
night yeah yeah yeah you know and then
how magical comes through and Steve
Ruggles of trying to do it though you
really bond with the people that are
going through the same thing is you you
bond I remember with Sebastian one time
I was like listen bro there's a gig in
Laguna Niguel or something
I go we go down there we get 15 minutes
which was like oh we get to do a lot of
time they do an hour special yeah and
they're gonna give us a salmon dinner
he's like I'm in so we're driving and
he's driving and I'm in the car and like
some car like almost like sideswiped we
almost like got killed like on the way
down I almost died gig the [ __ ] gig
can you believe so so we went through so
much [ __ ] with that and then and then
and then what happens is Mitzi puts us
together with me I met and and the guys
and then it eventually me I'm at an
errand realized look the only real
Middle Easterners in this group are the
three of us and are in our comedy place
to a specific audience and then 911 well
before 9/11 you know you guys what I'm
saying you guys well because I want you
to leave I want you to talk about yeah
building up to like this is all
happening yeah but then I'm what I'd
like you to talk about how like how 9/11
actually propelled you guys into like
whatever everything that happened well
it's interesting because so what
happened was 99 is when I started and I
think I'm ed was doing it around then or
maybe even before Aaron probably around
the same time and we were all taught we
were talking about being our back our
backgrounds we I mean it wasn't like
Osama bin Laden wasn't all right he was
around or terrorism had been around Iran
listen dude I've been dealing with this
[ __ ] since I landed I landed in 78 and
then the hostage crisis happened in 80
and it was just on and on from there
iran-contra my daughter it's been
ongoing uh-huh so when I started I would
talk about my Iranian is Iranian that
but Babar whatever my parents are and as
my fact it's evolved now to being like
immigrant this immigrant that cuz I
realized how much we all have in common
yeah but I'm doing all that Mitsy puts
us together as the Arabian Nights that's
what she calls it and
retirement originally in this
conversation we would do the show and
there be Iranian audience members who
come up afterwards we really enjoyed
this show but you know we're not Arabic
I know this older Jewish lady put it
together she owns the club and that's
what it's called
so then September 11th happens and be
honest with you like I was so upset
about like I mean I thought I could
never be funny again it's like the day
the music died I was like how could we
ever be funny again and I didn't want to
do stand-up again and as a matter fact I
had a I had a gig it was that Tuesday so
I had a gig I think that Saturday or
something at some private event in in
Orange County and I tried to cancel and
they were like no no you should come you
know the owner like his wife is Turkish
so they kind of you know they know of
the region and all that don't worry
about so I went there and it was
interesting because I had to really kind
of backpedal into my ethnic jokes made
you more thoughtful may be more
thoughtful but maybe we're like I was
really wary of like some people gonna
like jump at me you know Sam and I
remember I think midsi had told I met or
something that like I don't want you
guys going up this weekend is too hot
you know and in matter of fact up until
then she had done a couple of shows
where it was Arabian Nights like so when
when we would do our Arabian Nights
shows so for people that for people who
don't don't know you when you're a
regular at the club as you know you go
up throughout the week but then every
once in a while should be like it's
black night she was just decide yeah and
so it was like okay you know so there
was the same with the Arabian Nights
every like six months or so we do in
Arabian Nights in the main room and
eventually she was like why do you take
the Arabian Nights and go down to La
Jolla and at that time Tripoli would
come with us too so there was a four of
us so we were going down to an Arabian
desert and then eventually she goes when
September 11th happened she goes we
can't use that name for now like that's
too hot and it wasn't too like maybe six
months I don't know how far maybe a year
later when she sent us back down to La
Jolla and she was like we gotta we gotta
go back to you know to our plan get the
name back up so we had Arabian Nights on
the marquee at the La Jolla comedy store
and we get a call from the manager going
hey guys we just got a threat a death
threat someone said they're gonna come
down they were upset that we have that
up there I want to come they're gonna
come get you what do you guys think and
we were like you know what we don't
think it has teeth we think that it's
just a false threat let's go for it we
did the shows and they were great and
they were successful and as a matter of
fact once the Iraq war happened because
La Jolla is near Camp Pendleton we would
have Marines come to the show and they
were loved it they would come up to us
afterwards going man I'm happy you guys
are talking about this stuff cuz I've
been in the Middle East amazing though
right it was amazing because they were
like a lot of people don't know what you
guys are saying we've seen it like they
were you know say it funny how isn't it
funny how we doubt human nature so often
yeah that when things happen and we
think that we always think the worst
yeah I can totally understand that
you're these Middle Eastern comics and
then we just had this sort of attacked
it's that's being said it's from people
from the Middle East yeah and you think
nobody wants to hear us nobody wants to
try to us nobody wants to like you know
be involved and then they're like now we
you know let me see what you got to say
well a lot of people do but there's also
the people who are crazy you know
especially nowadays you see it right so
it's it's interesting because what you
were saying like once September 11th
happened and we started we started
getting a lot of press because we were
like who are these guys doing shows
right well how dare they but also like
on the other side going like what's good
like what's going on like they were
curious and what's interesting is I
think some people thought that like oh
we were taking advantage like we just
got into the game there was actually a
couple of dudes like a journalist who
decided to try stand-up after September
11th who was like a Arab descent and I
was like no no that's not us
I go worth comedians who were doing
comedy before right and just this
happened and we got to talk about it you
know saying yeah and so we got a lot of
press around it and I think that helped
propel us a little bit but more
importantly we just kept at it and we
were doing you know I always remind
people that like you said we came up to
the comedy store Laugh Factory we're
getting up five six ten times a week
yeah working our [ __ ] out working it out
we're actual comics so it just so
happens that's the topic we're talking
about and so eventually what happened
was I think we realized that like I said
that my aunt Erin and I made realize
okay this title Arabian Nights is not
first of all it doesn't encompass us
- it sounds like a Vegas show or like
Vegas your magic showing yeah like that
so we thought let's come up with an
edgier title so we took the name axis of
evil oh good I'm so late - I got a
little goosebumps but yes so so what
happened was so so what happened was
that we were I think I don't know who
actually coined that term between the
whole group
I've a Glee rememember doing we did like
some kind of a stand-up comedy showcase
so Fox was looking to find a person from
that part of the world to maybe try and
develop something with and I think all
of this goes back to if I'm not mistaken
whatever the year was 2003 2004 whatever
it was Omeed Jalili who was an Iranian
British comedian he had gone to Montreal
done great I mean he's great he's great
he's hilarious he forget from the mummy
the guy from The Mummy he's in he's in
the gladiator yes yes he's a great actor
he's a great actor
and he's very funny and so he had gone
to Montreal and he'd killed it and
gotten some sort of deal or like I think
some of the network's Brad we're excited
to get him on board yeah MBC landed him
and I think they were trying to do a
show with him and then Whoopi Goldberg
had her own show that year and there was
a janitor Whoopi was like running a
hotel and there's a janitor who works
there who I think was Russian in the in
the actual pilot and then somebody
thought well maybe Omid can play it as
an Iranian dude
so Omid was cast on that show and he had
a lot of heat so then the other networks
you know how it goes yeah it was like
well we need to get one in our Arab so
yeah so they put so Fox put together a
little showcase I was on it amid all the
guys were on it and there was a guy
named Shaun Majumder I don't remember
how Shaun was this Indian Canadian dude
who at the time was on Cedric the
Entertainer presents a sketch show
Cedric had a show on Fox with that yeah
Shaun was great Kyle Dunnigan was on
that show sure but uh but anyway so they
put the show together and I know if you
kind of mend it you're getting like see
how I have it you know like
I see I got you okay
cochlear failure so I think it was Sean
who coined the phrase it might have been
it might have been I meant I don't
remember who it was but at some point at
some point somebody said access it evil
hey it's access evil comedy whatever and
and it's stuck in our heads but nobody
did anything with it just kind of stood
there yeah and I think I'm mad you know
I met is very entrepreneurial he sure is
and so it's actually interesting because
I mad uh you know was smart enough to go
hey this is a title that something could
happen with and so I think he went and
shot a special maybe with Dean and
Maysoon Zayid Hutu Palestinian comedians
out of New York I think that's who was
on it but he basically like they were
performing somewhere and like a gym in
Detroit or something and I think that he
got there you go he got the he got like
a film crew to shoot it and they call it
access to evil I think and so this is
what's interesting because then nothing
really came of it was just kind of
sitting there was it was a title he had
that I think he was like maybe I don't
know how they were selling it or what
they were doing with I think somebody
might have bought it or something anyway
fast forward me aaron and ahmed realize
all right we are the were the heart of
this this thing and Arabian Nights ain't
gonna work out and I'm mad going back to
Ahmed being entrepreneurial
I met happens to be in DC for some event
he goes down to the DC improv Mitch
Mitch Hedberg is headlining oh wow and
Ahmed asks if he can get a guest spot
now Mitch is part Syrian it turns out I
didn't know this oh wow god I know this
so he kind of hits it off with Ahmed
he's like yeah bro go for it so I'm it
does this guest spot does great so the
manager goes hey why don't you come back
and I'm as I got this crew it's called
the Arabian Nights we can come back and
he's like yeah come back and do it do an
evening
so now DC has a big middle-eastern
population between Arabs Persians all
that stuff right and at the time I
always say it's like it's like a Waiting
for Godot in that there was an audience
waiting for us yeah they didn't know we
existed yeah but they were waiting for
they were like who's
boy who's our voice and so I'm ed gets
these guys to give us like a Tuesday
night at the improv it's like a 250
seater right so we do what we've done
before which is you know go to MySpace
and advertise it you know find the
student groups blah blah blah we go to
DC and we sell it out
not only do sell I think we do like two
shows or something and they're like whoa
who are these guys yeah yeah so then we
come back like they go listen let's give
you another date we get another date
like they go we'll give you a month
Tuesday Wednesday we come back Tuesday
Wednesday then like Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday we keep coming back we keep
killing it and then eventually I start
talking AHA man and I go listen man
these guys got to give us a weekend cuz
this [ __ ] ain't like they gotta give us
a weekend yeah they gotta allow us to up
the product we found I think they were
like I don't know charging like whatever
15 20 bucks a ticket and we're like look
at our audience they're affluent
yeah they'll pay more like we should
because because we would go up there
with me Ahmed and Aaron and we'd be like
alright we got to share a hotel room
price and we gotta like you know like
whatever the money but the money a 60/40
split or whatever yeah and I was like
listen dude we should be making more so
that we all are we're bringing it we're
bringing people to these guys is called
on on a weeknight yeah so we're like
we're totally on board with us so get on
a call with like the club managers and
stuff and they're like oh no no no we
don't feel like we should up the prices
because we know this market better I'm
like well how about adding a second show
on Thursday no we don't dude we're about
to go do a radio show on the top radio
station in DC I'm gonna announce first
show sold out let's do it no no no
finally were like screw this now this is
2004 and the reason I remember that is
because I I was on a TV show at the time
on Fox it was called life on a stick
which was like a hot dog on a stick
but like the TV show is about a bunch of
bunch of teenagers working at a hot dog
on a stick and I was there like Middle
Eastern manager right and you know when
you're on a TV show you get paid pretty
good money yeah so I told I'm at an air
and I go guys this is what we're gonna
do I said guys I got the money to put up
put it up front let's just go as
partners let's do it big let's just go
for it let's run a feeder
let's get a theater yeah and do access
to evil and the guys were on board let's
do it so I start calling I was basically
acting things like the agent I was
calling up the theater is going like how
much does it cost to ramp up
put down the money and it was amazing
because we got the Lisner auditorium
which sees 1,400 people and I always
tell people I go just do your own thing
go for it man don't wait for the people
to come around though in whatever you do
believe in yourself
gamble on yourself so we put the money
down listen I charge 49 people we talk
getting the word out getting the word
out there's gonna be big gonna be it's
the first access to evil show we hire
like it's gonna be me I'm ed Aaron and I
think we bring in either Dean or Maysoon
or both I forget what it was we had a
rapper we like made it a big thing I met
him ever I met admit a rapper who Bieber
we're like is gonna be a big night who
was like in the Arab world or something
yeah there's a guy named Narcy he's
amazing
Rocky Canadian he's amazing so we we go
alright we gotta go push this right cuz
Oh what happens is by the way Arabs and
Middle Easterners are notorious for
buying tickets last-minute yeah yeah
yeah so you guys were nervous out of
your [ __ ] nervous cuz on that Monday
Monday of a Friday show we have sold 700
tickets it's great still though feel
great but that's half of the audio and I
think it's 2005 and so that cuz because
actually it was the Friday cuz it was my
bachelor party and I missed my first
night of my bachelor party my buddies
went to Vegas without me and then I
showed up the next night so that Friday
by the time we went from Monday to
Friday we went from 700 tickets to 1400
tickets sold out people at the door any
tickets we don't have them you know that
whole week we would spend with our med
going to the clubs meeting people what's
up what are you guys doing shaking hands
what's up what's up what's up selling
tickets sold it out killed it
word gets back to the club like what
happened like yeah [ __ ] what
happened Yeah right
and so then our strategy was like
alright we just killed it here on our
own what's our next step I go alright
find all the Arab communities around the
country any community that has Arabs
Iranian with a Michigan no no before me
let me tell you so the next step was I
go listen guys I'm from Marin County in
Northern California Bay Area I go I
think we can I got enough contacts there
we can get some [ __ ] done so I hit up my
contacts in Marin Erin's hidden up like
the Palestinians and the Bay Area
Ahmed's hidden up his group there we go
we get a thousand cedar in San Francisco
boom sold it out boom right now word
starts getting back the
the person who at the time had a manager
was Erin with Abby Levinson right and
wart starts getting back to his manager
the people that my agents and stuff that
we're just doing because people are like
who are their promoters Live Nation no
no they're doing it themselves so I
don't like that they don't like that
Hollywood don't like that everybody
wants a piece and so word gets back and
so it's crazy because at the time oh
well you were talking about the Arab
things so because we were like exactly
we're like what's our next stop we go
Dearborn Michigan where all the Arabs
are yeah come to find out the Arabs
there were so so Arab that they weren't
into us they were not into a stand-up
group that's doing it all in English
again if we were like an Egyptian singer
or something if you speak to Arabic they
might loved it so you know we got like a
1400 seater but in Dearborn we only were
able to sell 700 seats like we couldn't
we didn't do as well as we did in the we
were doing much better in cosmopolitan
area statue so word gets back and then
between managers agents they start
setting meetings up and so levity
decides they want to shoot the special
JP I forget his last name Wilson or so
the guy who was at the time managing the
blue collar tour he wanted to sign us
and do a special we take some meetings
we decide we're gonna do with levity and
once we decide we're gonna do with
levity the way it all kind of comes
around is levity then says they will
shoot it in Southern California and I
think it was it was it was basically
shot and and I think end of 2006 and it
came out 2007 they sold at the Comedy
Central comes out in 2007 Comedy Central
and that's when we really like we we hit
the map because people we got a lot of
press around it we were like we were in
from from the New York Times to Playboy
The Hustler we were in everything and we
were like getting coverage and and then
what was amazing was we were getting
emails from people who were saying like
you know after September 11th I hated
Muslims but you know watching you guys
made me realize there's good people
everywhere because it wasn't just us it
was also the audience or
people and so that really helped us and
at the same time YouTube was just
starting to take off
so people were taking our clips and
email back their memory you would like
they would email it you would see
everyone's email address so I could see
my own clips coming back at me like
several times I'm like what is going on
and that's when suddenly because before
that I've been the only people that knew
me were people that had seen Friday
after next and knew me as moley from
Friday afternoon Rui Rui Rui suddenly
I'm being known as Maz Jobrani because
of my clips and again
tom has credit he had met somebody this
guy named Jimmy LaGuardia out of the
Middle East who Jamil is another guy who
is entrepreneurial and he told Ahmed why
don't you guys bring this to the Middle
East I think it's gonna be big and so
that's why understatement understand
mister end of 2007 so our so our our
special came out on Comedy Central 2007
in the spring then we did a US tour and
then we were able to take that and go to
the Middle East and the 2007 do it
toward there it was the first time there
was a group of American comedians even
though we're of Middle Eastern descent
were Americans who had had success in
America who were coming to the Middle
East to perform for the people of the
Middle East rise and that got crazy
because we went there and we did like 27
sold-out shows in 30 days in five
countries and we went I said I feel like
we were money was dumb the money was
dumped and we became I think we I think
I always say like flying over the
Atlantic we've we turn into the Beatles
because dude I was just gonna say Mike's
okay okay so you doing all those and I
guess the second time around is when you
started to bring people yeah so what
happened was so throughout I mean it's
known now like I met an Aaron we're
always butting heads there was always
some conflict going on and I was playing
I was always trying to play Kofi Annan
but eventually in the end of 2007 so we
we port that's what I'm sorry to cut in
that's right so you guys were going as
axis of evil and so at the breakup of
axis of evil you guys decided to go from
the guys that brought you axis of evil
exactly so again going back to like what
we had to do deal with was like okay so
we're all owners like it's like it's a
band right so when you have a
and you're all partners you can't just
say see you later
we're gonna use the name yeah so we had
to find a creative way so I met and I
would take from the guys who brought you
actually evil yeah and give it some name
like you know Maz I met and friends or
IMed mazda whatever it is yeah and we
started bringing people that we thought
were going to be able to translate in
the region you can't bring just anybody
you can't yeah you know if you bring
somebody who's like doing jokes about
like oh you know the 405 in the 101 you
know there's gonna be like what yeah
what is photo so transy so we started
bringing I think we like the guys that
we brought on and like you said it was
such a it was the beginning of what now
going now 12 years later you go to the
Middle East and every country's got its
own comedy so yeah it's crazy
but it's the beginning of that so when
we would show up it was like it was like
Major League Baseball chill over
whenever NBA showed up like holy [ __ ]
these guys are huge she's not only we
were huge but we were all good comics
and bringing other good comics I wasn't
saying that first time around that first
tour when you went to those 27 Arab
cities oh yeah yeah or just middle
eastern cities yeah and you guys like
you were trying I didn't mean to cut you
off but yeah you definitely would like
the reverse of the Beatles you were cuz
you guys cuz I witnessed it myself just
on this one it wasn't that and I was
like this is incredible well yeah come
on it was crazy because when we landed
and Dubai they're like oh we're gonna
have a press conference I'm like who's
coming to our press conference and we go
to this rooftop and there's like 20
different news outlets you know question
question how is it like being in America
intimately I'm a Muslim holy [ __ ] and
then like like you said people are
recognizing us stopping us take a
picture and that's what and we're
selling I mean like Dubai was crazy like
we did we did like ten shows at like 450
seat theaters and then at the end we did
like a 2,000 seat outdoor show I mean it
was crazy and then people are not only
that what you guys need to understand is
people are over there paying like like
Chris Rock don't even get particular
over there with those depends what
country you were in like Dubai at the
time it was before the crash so there
was a lot of money and when we go to
Cairo Egypt is poor yeah yeah so there
oh I can only get seven bucks a ticket
but but you still have 1500 2000 people
showing up yeah anyway so we so so then
we have to figure out who can we bring
that's gonna translate so we started
bringing you Sebastian Angelo tsarouchas
Dean Edwards Ted Alexandro yeah I'm
trying to think who else there was a
handful of guy Lee Bobby well Bobby Lee
came on the ledge so so then Ahmed went
back so Ahmed then again being good at
this stuff like he really took it to the
next level and did a whole documentary
right that's like us just like us and so
I think he then was like I'm gonna bring
Whitney Cummings Tom Papa Bobby Lee he
went to the next level with it I was
just coming like I didn't I didn't take
the producing angle as much from that as
I was like I'll go out and perform and
bring the guys and we'll go have a good
time it was it was great I think at the
time was great we were all making pretty
good money doing it well I remember that
first time I went with you guys it was
like in Beirut and I'm sitting here in
this theater like seeing all these
people I'm like what is happening right
now yeah I mean I'm - I was like like
you know and then like we're sitting in
like our long line of people taking
pictures yeah yeah wanting stuff it was
like I'm sure the merch and the and all
that stuff was just it just it really is
an incredible thing to watch people how
much they really adore do you guys well
it goes back to I think part of it is
you realize like how when we demonize
other people you go wait a minute
everyone really is similar around the
world they just want to laugh they want
to they want to like you know feed their
family want a job that's what they want
right so the and by the way a YouTube
helped a lot mm-hmm
because then people have seen these
clips I mean he was over there over
there like the king of Jordan saw a
special invited us to the palace oh he
was like he's old as he goes yes some he
goes I go on he goes I ride Harley's in
California in the summer and one of the
Harley dudes handed me the the DVD I
watched it I loved it I advised you guys
so he came to our show I mean so you
know people were finding us and also the
rest of the world a lot of these
countries you know they're there
an educated class that's learning
English understands English and knows
English well enough to understand the
jokes yeah and so you can go to places
like Beirut and Cairo and Kuwait and
when do shows and people gonna show up
yeah well being in Egypt I don't never
forget that I'm about to go onstage and
I had these like jokes about like you
know and I remember saying to a man I
was like are you sure you want me to do
these jokes and he was like don't do it
it's gonna be great yeah and it was just
like I was like ah this I felt like a
superstar
bro I'll tell you it's interesting cuz I
just having just done Jakarta for the
first time ever its Indonesia I'd never
even been there before and they speak a
different language you dealt with a mid
did you go I just went I just went like
just like a few weeks ago I was I was I
did I did a tour I was out there he's
out in Malaysia oh I don't know if he's
there right now but I did I basically
did uh I did Australia and on the way
back at this Singapore and then I did
Jakarta and both Singapore in Jakarta
first time ever audience mostly Asian
you know not even not even Arabs mostly
Asian Wow and I and and son also Jakarta
by the way is a lot of people speak
English but most people speak Indonesian
or that languages so I'm sitting there
going like are these people gonna
exactly we just said I was like and my
opening act was a local dude who was
very funny who's got the worst so he's
he knows the street names he loved it
killing it and he's doing it in English
but he's killing it he's like doing a
masturbation joke and I was like you can
do masturbation's just because this it's
like it's Indonesia's the biggest the
most populated Muslim country in the
world but it's probably like Beirut
where everything goes it kind of is I
think it's that they're so poor that
they're like we're just gonna have fun
we're gonna live our lives so I was
watching this guy killed I'm like oh my
god how am I gonna go because by the way
you know cultural differences right like
the way I'm raising because I do a lot
of material about raising my kids yeah
and raising kids in America is like all
talking to them how do you think we
should deal with this problem and then
raising your kids still in some parts of
the world there you just bank them yeah
in Singapore we were in the mall I saw
some Chinese lady smack her
three-year-old yeah and I looked at my
wife on my holy [ __ ] you were ready to
call child services oh hell no I was
ready to move to Singapore
yeah cuz your kids are bad yeah you know
that yeah yeah you know my kids man they
know you well it was funny you think you
know you so like we did that time we
were jfl and you were hosting your kids
in the green room yeah
just terrorizing everybody so fun man
one of my favorite pictures of this day
is a picture of you and my daughter Mila
going up a flight of stairs and you guys
are both looking back it's so beautiful
man
but you don't know it was like the
people came to us you know like like
secretly it was like are you guys okay
with these kids here yeah you know yeah
tell us like you know and I said I was
like I was like don't worry about it if
we really have a problem we could tell
Maz ourselves in that crazy when you
have that I've had that before where
people like are way too official yeah
I'm like just talk to me I've had that
before who like oh I'm you know is is is
is the Evian water okay I'm like just
ask me why are you talking to my manager
what's up everybody
football seasons here and I want to talk
to you about my bookie what a crazy
start to the season already you know
with Antonio Brown
he's with the Raiders now he's with the
Patriots and is he gonna play or is he
not gonna play Le'Veon Bell is he hurt
or not what's going on over there in New
York it's Cleveland gonna get their
nonsense together I don't know but if
you enjoy betting on games in game
betting prop bets all that great stuff
you need to go to my bookie with all
these crazy changes in the NFL season
there's one thing that hasn't changed
where I put my money down on all the
games and that's my bookie it's the
place to bet on football every weekend
one of my favorite things about my
bookie is that you could bet on fantasy
sports you could bet the over-under on
how many times I'm gonna to score your
fantasy team's gonna bet I made three
fantasy leagues right now so you know I
wanna bet on my fantasy guys and I want
to bet on the real football game so it
keeps you invested both ways make sure
you bet responsibly I know you Benton
responsibly because you listening to
River Griffin so you a responsible type
person up to $1,000 first deposit bonus
double your first deposit use promo code
riffin to activate the offer visit my
bookie online today that
my bookie my B oh okay ie and don't
forget to use the promo code riffin when
creating your account to claim the
bonuses bet when get paid now let's
continue with the podcast I had one dude
I did a club I did a comedy club in in
in San Diego and just crazy dude that
what's it called the American comedy
club oh yeah I was gonna say it must be
Justin yeah I don't know what the dude's
name is but I had miron's EO came down
with me Marazzi Oh Vance very funny you
know of our left you know our level like
and morontia was a hey man you know
whenever you want someone to featured
love to hang out and I was like that's
great I mean when you get a guy who's
headliner level saying I'll come feature
hang out with you he's your buddy let's
do it like a weekend out of it we go
down we did a two-man show and whatever
he's gonna do 20 I'm gonna do an hour
and I think the first night he does like
25 right it's like a Thursday there's
not even a second show and I'm I don't
care just I'm like this great we can we
go we go two hours everyone yeah so then
the next day I get a call from my
manager ray going hey man um did you
guys kind of go long yes and I go I have
no idea he goes yeah they're saying the
Marazzi Oh to 20-foot I go all right I
go why are they calling you why don't
they just tell us and by the way I'm the
headliner by the way I filled that room
that we can that Thursday night if it's
an issue of oh I got to pay my staff
extra to stay five minutes more let me
know but just talk to me
and so and raise really cause I got I
don't know these people are trippin all
right people tripping man but this is
what they want to do did it so then the
next day I get another call and Ray goes
hey man if you were on zio break this
there's a bullhorn that they had in the
bathroom because in the greenroom
there's a bathroom for the artist and
there's a bullhorn and that's what's
used to like hang like whatever if you
want to hang your coat or switch so the
bullhorn had broken and he goes did you
or Marazzi break I go [ __ ] no I go
Marazzi did you go when you were in the
bathroom did you see that for he's like
no man but he goes but
dunno the staff was coming in and using
our bathroom I was like Rea what is
wrong with this dude
and I was like that made me that put a
bad taste in my mouth
and I said I'm never performing here
again come out exactly I don't know
exactly what you're saying
now I gots to deal with that and by the
way it was a great blessing in disguise
cuz now I go back to my home club the La
Jolla Comedy Store - that's where I
perform when I go down it's like that's
my people yeah you know and they'll pay
you good yes like why am I gonna go deal
with some of this other nonsense yeah
everybody all these little fiefdoms you
know they think that like comedy started
it there little [ __ ] not only that
it's not only that but it's also I will
tell you what it is it goes back to the
idea of just communicate with me you
don't need to make it a big deal and run
it up management I'm I'm an adult I can
handle it so the same thing with when
you were saying my kids were running
around backstage just come talk to me
and be like hey Matt Maz you kids or I
think that they were trying to gauge if
everyone else was okay with it
meanwhile everybody I mean there's
pictures of us like I know but it was
just funny because it was like we I'm
gonna handle it myself I'm just gonna
tease you about it exactly cuz like
we're dudes back here Kirsten and you're
like guys language yeah his mom's too
cheap for daycare I saw your kid was out
I guess he was out with his friends
family and we're just out on the street
right and then I was like hey I saw him
he was like man they know they know you
they know Angelo we had a great time
there's another one of my favorite
pictures is when Angelo would do that
whole thing of like Eric I'm not feeling
well yeah there's a picture of my kids
pushing Angelo on to you is brilliant
there's a big chunky dude yeah we
anyways going back to it is like you
have I've had some really amazing times
going to the Middle East I went on this
like and just remembered I had to write
a journal it was so it was so crazy
funniest things to me was when you and
Sebastian went to get the tour at the
pyramids I mean hilarious
we're out here we spent like five
hundred dollars it was and you guys $45
a tour yeah you guys asked the promoter
how much is about an a leg you know
there may be like
you go you go how much is it how much
should be how much would it toward the
parents guys are like maybe $20 you're
like oh we just got ripped off
we just got ripped off the guy it was so
hilarious
I mean I went with a med and a group we
had like one of the first comedy shows
in Syria yeah I remember that born in
Damascus and like me and I got like
super-sick there though but what were
you like but but what a beautiful city
and it's just shame that like maybe a
lot of people will never be able to see
it absolutely cut you like going to it's
amazing though because like going to
Saudi Arabia 12 years ago is so
different from I just went we just went
just went in different world
how different is it because I remember
when we went back 12 years ago it was
like we had to perform at some consulate
and it's all these religious police
everywhere and it was very much like be
careful what you say and all that kind
of stuff like we only could go to
certain places cut - we're walking
through the streets now and there's
music playing and Backstreet Boys are
there women children walking out I'm at
a show where men and women are all
sitting together and they're trying to
open the place up they're trying to be
the new Dubai I think that they realized
I think what happened was they realized
that they cannot count on just the oil
they need to attract business yeah the
world because the world is moving on
words are moving on and and places like
Dubai and Doha and Abu Dhabi and those
places are taking all this business so a
lot of European and American companies
will set up shop in those other Gulf
countries you won't go to Saudi Arabia
because there was all this welcome yeah
and also like and also by the way like
one of the things the guy was telling me
he goes right now now in Saudi Arabia
like women can drive there one minute
you know if there's an uber and stuff
it's crazy and if women don't want to
cover themselves up is not as big of a
deal and and but he said the one thing
they haven't done yet is to legalize
alcohol in at least the American hotels
or the Western hotels but he said he I
think that is coming because what's
gonna happen is again going back to like
your Brits or whatever I when you go to
Dubai there's a ton of Brits - yeah yeah
and they love the fact that they can go
to a bar and drink and do whatever they
want so I think it unless if there's
some major
backlash I think that's coming as well
to realize Pauly Shore went right so
Paulie went yeah Holly call he hits me
up he's like buddy why didn't you tell
me you can't drink on the fly I know I
know
buddy hey kool-aid - man it was funny
yeah it's funny so it's like look
whether you don't look where the world
is that so what do you think the state
of it is now I mean as this person
you've been you you you were at the
inception of like you know the the Arab
Spring of comedy right yeah now here you
are sometime later you still traveling
yeah business isn't it could be I mean I
I spent a car cease travel I mean that's
just going to the Middle East but like
well no over so here's what your
overseas here's what I say what I think
is that it used to be like 30-some odd
years ago before you and I got into it
like there was a time where you're the
comedy circuit was I'm going to
Cleveland I'm going to Toledo I'm going
now not just me but anybody can go to
many places yeah including Australia New
Zealand Australia great all the
Scandinavian countries in Europe I just
did shows for the first time ever in
France in a world and I was a little
worried about that because I had heard
that the French Spaniards Italians don't
speak English well enough to understand
a stand-up comedy show in English but
there's enough people there it's a it's
it's Paris so it's a big city so it's
gonna be cosmopolitan yeah in all
honesty I did like I did I did I did
London and I did Scandinavia and I did
Paris and my hottest show was the Paris
show Wow
I mean it was like rock and roll 400
people and they were they were French
and there were Tunisians and there was
Persians and there was Lebanese and they
all got it cuz people are travelling
people are seeing YouTube that's why I
think I personally feel like look it's a
double-edged sword right the social
media internet we're getting a lot of
like you know extremist views and
prosperity theories all that but at the
same time we are getting people in
oppressed places seeing how the rest of
the world is living and in my opinion
and and my hope is that that that will
lead to these countries that are
oppressive whether it's China or
somewhere in the Middle East or wherever
realizing they can't keep their people
down yeah you know what I'm saying
people want to be able to express
themselves people want to be able to
criticize their leaders that's why
whenever I do whenever people get upset
at me making a Trump go
I'll go look that's the point of this
country is that we can cut other places
you can't you know can't and so we you
know appreciate that like you know I
think a lot of people like as somebody
who was born in another country and I
got my eye on Iran and I see the
oppressive regime that's there I feel
like let's not go that route let's not
don't don't don't tell me I had some
lady come to show in Dallas and the
shows were great and then she sent me an
email afterwards going I was enjoying
the show until you started making fun of
our leader or whatever one of those and
she was like the same way that you would
expect respect from a child you should
give our leader respect so I was like
wait a minute you are now analogizing me
to a child I go do you understand how
backwards the thinking is yeah take
advantage of the fact that you can and
even if you don't agree with what I'm
saying at least defend the fact that I
can do that have the right to do it so
you know yes you've always been like
it's Missy recently you are talking
about being a dad you talk about your
kids a lot yes you also I always
consider you a very conscious comic like
very aunt like right on the political
forefront yeah and all the things that's
been going on in the world so what do
you think about how that is and how it's
affected your comedy yeah you know in
all honesty like I feel like sometimes I
get and I think the world I think
America I think we we get exhausted by
it because sometimes I hear people talk
about comedians talk about I don't want
to talk about politics because people
come there to escape right and so a lot
of times I think to myself alright you
know what just do this 15 20 minutes set
don't even go there because I out I it
also brings me down yeah as a matter
fact I stopped like I did a tweet a
little while back ago I have been
avoiding any tweets or any news from
Donald Trump and I feel so good and it
was true it because it just because it
takes you in you notice April but then
what will happen is I'll be watching
Colbert and he'll be and I love cold
and he'll do something he'll mention or
tweet that he the trumpet and I'll go
look at I go he actually said that [ __ ]
and it pisses me off so and I have to
talk about it so it right if I feel like
I have to talk about I talk about it
people tell me sometimes online you know
on social media you're a comedian stick
to comedy I go I'm a human being
just cuz you're an accountant doesn't
mean you don't have political opinions
by the way I said it political science
by the way I like reading this stuff I
read the newspaper I'm intrigued about
this stuff and I see what I see and it
bothers me as an immigrant I feel I have
to speak up because I feel like I was
lucky enough to come to a country at a
time when there was turmoil in my
country and we were able to land here
and be accepted and Here I am 40 years
later living my dream and so when you
tell me that they're gonna put a travel
ban and turn away people who are running
away from a war in Syria and they're
landing on our shores and we're saying
no we just decided to have a travel ban
even though we vetted you and your
family for two three years and you were
approved to come here but now we're
telling you you can't come here you got
to go back to that situation where you
most likely would get killed I say I got
to stand up for that guy and I got to
say to you know that guy's not a
terrorist that guy's coming here to make
his life better I got to tell you they
let's look at the statistics and realize
that none of the countries on the travel
ban have had a person from their country
commit an act of terror in America but
you have put these countries into this
thing and I'm getting emails from people
from Iran going hey I'm a student in
Iran who excelled in my class and I'm
trying to come to America to study make
my life better I can't come where I'm
getting emails from people in America
going I married an Iranian I'm an
American and my wife her husband is not
able to come because of this travel ban
or I'm reading things of people saying
like they can't come like somebody had
it there was an article on a guy who I
think his son it was a in America died
and the guy was coming for the funeral
and they won't even make that exception
for him to come to his son's funeral so
that's that kind of stuff to me it's
like so we're then so then where then
does how do you balance the ratio
between entertainment and information
great and your passion for these topics
how do you like make those things
entertaining I basic
like I once I got into stand-up III
realized that prior was somebody who I
really liked because I was like oh he's
on my social issues with a punchline
Carlin was another one right there and I
said god I really and even the Daily
Show watch that stuff and then I and
then there's a line and a Public Enemy
song he got game they go [ __ ] the game
if it ain't saying nothing and I was
like yeah [ __ ] the game if it ain't
saying it I love political art like if
there's art and there's politics
underneath it whether it's Marvin Gaye's
you know what's going on or or it's uh
or it's Public Enemy's fight the power
whatever it is I'm Marley um I'm like
that I'm about that so I sometimes catch
myself first of all on social media I'll
get a little carried away like like with
this with the recent shootings I got
really upset so there was a couple post
that I had to do that I was like I got
to just get this off my chest
and I realized the more you talk from
your passion you're gonna get cussed out
a lot but the people that support you
are gonna be there I mean you're gonna
you're gonna it's almost like it helps
you saying it's worth the risk it's
worth the risk because I'm gonna to say
just to jump on this what you're talking
about is like cuz what we're talking
about you don't necessarily have to
please everybody it's in the process of
trying to please everybody you don't
please anyone and so you say I have
these passionate subjects I'm gonna talk
about them and the ones that are with me
they're gonna come to my shows
absolutely and I think that you grow a
fanbase when people go oh this guy's got
balls and he's talking cuz I love like I
like I like those people yeah and so so
that's number one and be honest with you
there's a lot of immigrants even within
the Persian community who love Trump so
I've turned off a lot of these people
and I go listen that's fine if you can't
handle it then please don't come to my
show like I was jokingly saying you keep
it entertaining but I feel like you're
doing one oh so I was saying jokingly I
was saying like my shows I recommend for
PG 14 because there's gonna be some
cussing and people who can handle the
Trump joke it's a joke and so and so the
way I handle it is first of all social
media that's that and then I try then if
I see that I've done like way too like
if I feel like I've done three or four
my last post we're all passion passion
passion I try to go this next one he's
gotta be goofy mm-hmm so like I did a
whole thing of me singing the Jonas
Brothers and I posted it and I was like
it's silly and it's like just like it
conflates all the tension right now when
it comes to
and up this is interesting is I was
doing a show at the at the Melrose
improv Hollywood improv and I and I've
gotten to the point in my head where I
said you know what I'm really gonna
delve into why I don't like Trump and
there were several reasons one of them
was that he is a bully and I got bullied
when I came to America back then they
would call this [ __ ] Iranian and I
got called [ __ ] Iranian by 6th grader
when I was in the fourth grade so I said
I think I've learned early on that I
want to stand up to bullies gotcha
another reason I was saying was even
this is like some kind of like therapy I
was like he reminds me a little bit of
my dad my dad was a businessman
my dad was conservative so there was
some of that so I was finding the
reasons and I was working through that
and I was doing like this this like long
segment that might have been like a
10-15 minute segment on Trump now few
times when I was doing that there would
be some Persian person in the audience
who likes him because a lot of Iranians
I think bought into the idea that he's
gonna help overthrow the regime in Iran
and then if I criticized him to go with
it you're on the side of the regime I go
no man I don't like the regime I don't
like him
I can criticize both but so what
happened was gonna do if he brings peace
to the Middle East listen dude I give
I'll give credit where credit is due so
after the shooting and I think it was it
might have been the Parkland High I
forget forget which one it was but one
of those shootings he brought people
into the White House and he was having a
little summit and he was talking and
asking them questions and I actually
tweeted I go I'm gonna give credit where
credit is due he's brought them over
here and he's listening to them and then
the next day he comes out he's like we
need the armed teachers I go this
[ __ ] so so I'll give credit
where credit is due
he's great so anyway so I was at the in
Melrose Hollywood improv I'm doing some
bit and it was kind of a long extended
bit and this one dude starts going like
you know he's he's great or whatever
he's so and I go we talking about then I
get in a discussion with him and then I
and then I tried it like now I realize
I've abandoned my show and I'm I'm
actually in a debate with the guy I go
listen dude I go listen you might like
him and I don't like him but I go let's
just call a spade a spade I go if you
came to me and said I said I said I
liked Obama and if you can
me and said under obama there was the
most drone attacks against pakistan and
that killed innocent people i would say
you're right obama wasn't perfect he had
a lot of [ __ ] that he did it wasn't good
so when i come to you and i say to you
that his rhetoric is causing people to
go out and you know do all some of this
hate hate hate trade and stuff or if i
say to you that he said grime by the
[ __ ] or whatever i say just say let you
gotta we gotta agree on the facts it was
like no this that and then i and i was
like i go what about the travel ban i go
you're I know you're persian he goes
yeah i go look at the travel ban which
isn't allowing innocent iranians that
want to come like study here and live
here and separating families what about
that well whatever it's like it's good
for our security i go bro none of these
people and i'm debating him and i go
were you born in america he goes no I
came to America that pisses me off if I
go you you took advantage of the
immigration rules and now you're saying
like you closed the door so I got pissed
up and then some of the other audience
members start going hey whatever the
comedy shows oh [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
when I realized so that's why I reminded
myself I go look to the best of my
ability I'm first of all I cut back on
the amount of stuff I was I made it I
tamed it I told I told you you really
been thinking about this I brought it
down a little bit I go I go the audience
has uh uh has the the palate for it for
a limited amount of time my audience
some audiences might you might be like
Sarah Silverman somebody might be like
do a whole half an hour or something oh
yeah yeah my audience is limited palette
so I go I'm gonna tone it down the other
thing I'm gonna do I said is next time
somebody yells at me I'm just gonna
smile big I'm just gonna be a hey man
it's all good I love you it's fine if
you don't want to be here you don't have
to be here yes I got a I got Instagram
hit me up we'll talk about it and it
happened I was at the Irvine improv and
there's a lot of conservatives in Irvine
and his lawyer rich Persians who like to
dude I'm getting in my Trump stuff and
some dude I could see him in a full room
I could see him in the back uh-huh
pacing back and forth back and forth and
I'm like what is this dude doing as you
know you're doing your set you do the
jokes but your eyes are on this guy I'm
like is this guy gonna go pee what is he
trying to get the bill next thing I hear
is like [ __ ] you cuz
like what father and I'm like hey man I
do the thing I go huh it's all good now
my audience starts attacking here I go
no guys calm down yeah I go hey man
namaste it's all good I go listen that's
your opinion
I got my opinion I don't like the guy
that's my hey that's my problem
listen I and the guy left and then I
actually named my current poor peaceful
warrior
because of that I'm like I still want to
be a warrior let me be a peaceful
warrior well that's interesting balance
that you're talking about trying to
balance between like what we are is like
you want to be a truth teller which is
not a prerequisite of comedy by the way
this is I'm fine with people that
exaggerate I'm fine with people that are
you know making things up because it's a
skill to make it seem real right that's
part of what we do right yeah I mean
yeah and it's like you know so the you
know you being an entertainer as opposed
to being a professor yeah and that's
like sometimes I said I see you I see
you when you're in that mode and I'm
like ah professor Jobrani is here
everybody was funny because I had one
time Sebastian followed me at the Comedy
Store in the original room and he comes
up he's like I don't talk about Paula
you would never know what I believe he's
like whatever it is funny because I want
to like you said if I can just bring a
punchline to it if I get that laugh and
still I get when I got that letter from
that lady in Dallas I still was it was a
show that in all honesty the the the
audience was diverse I was in Dallas
Texas and they were had it was I felt
like oh my god this was a great night
and I still got people that were upset
and now what I do is again getting into
the Trump stuff I first I lead off with
a joke I used to do under the Bush
administration which is reminding them I
go cuz I do one Trump joke and then I go
I know some people get upset when I do
Trump jokes but I can I go I have
friends I have Republican friends that
get upset and I remind them I still love
you just because we disagree on certain
I still love you and I go by the way I
go I go I tell them that we can make fun
of our leaders that's why we should do
it I go whether it's Republican Democrat
I go look at the Democratic debates I go
that's like a Saturday in our life
schedule I know this is traditionally as
a comedian yeah we got a killer you know
we gotta like go at our prayer
so I phone it down like that and then I
go listen by the way I go listen when it
comes to Trump we all I go I have my
issues you have your issues ago you
might have voted for him I go that's
between you and your therapist and that
usually gets a laugh or a clap and then
I go I got my own issues I go whatever
he says pisses me off I go the other day
I woke up and I he had a tweet I said
good morning I go this is [ __ ]
yeah afternoon he's lying again so that
leads me into my thing I'm trying to
disarm them yeah we'll also let them
know this is where I stand this is where
I stand in the what's good about that is
to let people know like if you're just
saying like hey listen I don't like
Trump so that's where everything's
coming from then the people could be
like okay they don't have to be so like
serious about it but it's just a weird
balance I mean when I first like about a
couple years ago when all that you know
right after Trump got in office it was
like a lot of tension on the road yeah
of course it was very tense yeah I
remember being in st. Louis and I was
like what the [ __ ] happening because
it was like I felt like the Republican
audience members were mad yes
I'm like you won and then the in the
Liberals were too sensitive yeah yeah it
was like [ __ ] can I do comedy with this
yeah if so it just made us like you say
you had to think about Iraq I just think
it's making like and then you are then
on top of that you add me too so yeah
it's like a whole thing of like making
everything more thoughtful and you know
and I think if you take like 30 seconds
to explain what I just kind of like it
to go like look I know some of you guys
would be offended as it stands is where
I stand I might be an [ __ ] to you
yeah but listen there's an hour show
there's only five minutes of it because
that's what you know my beginning of my
show is usually like kid kid kid getting
older it's like personal self
deprecation now we do a little bit of
Trump stuff now we're gonna end it with
some other silly [ __ ] I just put it in
the middle so again like I said I got
that weekend I got two emails both of
them were like I was enjoying the show
until I don't look at the whole show and
have a sense of humor about it yeah and
relax and by the way I tell them I go
just cuz that's another line I had it
there ago I'm making fun I'm making fun
of the present or not making fun of your
grandmother yeah
like relax is not personal but if your
grandmother had weird hair and she
talked like Zeus I'm a [ __ ] too
listen if this mother if I could stop
tweeting maybe I stop talking about him
but you know what I mean it's like I
think if Twitter was around for 50 years
yeah I mean this
he's just the first and also and also
listen I feel like he's using it it's a
tool I feel it's important to punch up
so if I can't like I never like people
go what's what's off-limits for you I go
I would never make fun of someone that's
like handicapped I just don't I don't
feel comfortable doing that I do I know
I know I know some comics doing that's
fine I don't judge it because they want
to be like everyone else exactly but I
don't feel comfortable so whatever it is
I just don't struggle but I go I go I
like to punch up so whoever that person
is you know whether it's Joe Biden or
its snooze fest or is Trump then I'm
gonna make fun of it right or you know
so I don't know man it's what interests
me end of the day is like what interests
me and if that turns you off they just
don't come to my show well here's my
thing for you right now I because I have
a thing in my I say that my problem with
liberals is they love to hate Trump more
than they like any particular Democratic
candidate well the problem right now is
in and I'll be I'll be guilty of it is
it I think there's so many that it's
like all right who where are we gonna go
now I look at what they a lot of them
are standing for and I go I agree with
most of this stuff whether it's a
climate change thing whether it's a gun
control thing whether it's a foreign
foreign policy thing I agree with most
of what they're all saying now and I
feel that out of that group the cream is
gonna arise like there's gonna be I know
but the creams good needs to be pushed
forward too though and what I'm saying
is I think that like the hipster you
know liberal elitist people right you
know and you fall into this category
right you know I mean you're you're
affluent you're like you know you spend
more time talking about Trump
then you do talking about like whoever
well but the truth but the truth is
because again Trump is day-to-day and
these guys pot are now starting to pop
more and more so it's funny because they
you say that because I am I am obsessed
with Trump news so I'll turn on the news
and they'll be like we're now at Iowa
State Fair where the Democrats I'm a man
is abortion
eating's what'd I say like what nobody
listen the fact is as we get closer and
closer I think that then you will
because first of all the 1% 2% guys are
gonna fall away I personally feel like
between between I like Biden but he's
too old in my opinion I can't he's
nothing he's not gonna win a debate
which he's not sharp is that confirms
gonna be like yeah are you awake over
there so so I think between these are
the few that like to me I go okay these
guys could pop so between your Biden
Elizabeth Warren Bernie
cam Allah Buddha jej paid oh maybe
Corrie out of those seven I feel like
someone is gonna come up like I
personally thought Pamela I like Camelot
but a lot of a lot of people that are on
the left are like she was hard on
criminals but and I'm like well that's
good that she's a little more centrist
cuz she might be able to get some more
of the people in the middle that wanna
want to support but then I sit then I go
maybe the woman thing is gonna play and
I honestly feel like part of it is
America's still sexist [ __ ] I always say
we're more sexist than we are racist you
know what I'm saying
so that might hold her back okay but
here's my point mods I'm trying to make
here is that I think that people like
yourself and like even these late-night
people because they they should send
Trump a gift basket every day right
thank you for my ratings right you don't
mean because just the Todd constant
talking it's Saturday Night Live yeah
but it was a dead show and then all of a
sudden you know their their wins and
it's like yeah in the back of Trump all
I'm trying to say is as much so if you
talk about Trump one time I think five
times after that you need to talk about
someone that you think is doing
something good that should replace him
because with that because all he's all
were doing is giving the guy more press
and he will win again well the fact is I
have said this to him I get I mean I
think I've said it about Harlem page I
said this about him he is a master
publicist like if he had a publicity
firm he would be the best one ever said
he's a great politician because we're
not good at Paula
yeah because what you said what you just
said is an interesting thing because
even when there isn't like you'd be like
oh there whatever the Democrats are at
the State Fair talking about you know
whatever it is universal health care and
he'll come on and be like you know black
people you know are monkeys or
what-have-you be like why did he just
say that
and then and then he'll just steal all
that thunder so he constantly is saying
crazy like the picture of him with the
baby whose parents had been killed in
Ohio know in in it was Ohio or or El
Paso I think I don't if you saw the
picture but there's a picture at the
hospital there's a baby whose parents
were shot in that massacre
milania's holding the baby and Donnie's
standing there with the thumbs up and a
big smile on his face
now some people that defend him are like
no he was saying thumbs up the kid's
gonna be okay we're gonna take care of
it I'm like first of all this kid's
parents were killed in a massacre when
you're there and they're like we're
about to take a picture you tell Melania
let me hold that baby hey check this out
though and I'm not in defense of him
yeah this is not 1975 where there's only
one camera fine you know you were you
know who's gonna take the picture where
it is or where he is straight-up posing
it's not like he was smiling at the baby
and someone caught him smiling I go why
is he smiling no he's straight-up posing
but captured moments manner so that's so
easy to capture somebody you know how it
is like makes them like look bad and he
said I agree I agree with you but at the
same time that picture pissed off so
many people and took the headlines all
of a sudden from any other subject we
might have been able to talk about by
the way it's probably more heated and
sexier to get into that than it is to
the nitty gritty gun control healthcare
healthcare differences packages between
Sanders and warrior I don't even know
what their differences are yeah bro
that's why the guys gonna win again this
get this we got to make it sexy I feel
if you if you really are anti Trump you
got to get out there or it's gonna be
another ass woman well that's I agree
with you and I feel that I feel that
really it's gonna come down to those
three or four swing states really see I
know the guys are brilliant politician
and I guy was I was having an argument
this actress friend of mine and she was
like heal chunks an idiot and I was like
whoa I was like be careful because
you're dismissing let that's a
dismissive statement and yeah you're not
respecting your enemy right because I
remember seeing I saw this on The Daily
Show and like they had it was just rally
he was having that you know and and he
was like he was saying these words he
was like you know they told me to say
drain to swamp
you know and I didn't like that at first
I didn't like it but they said hey it's
gonna work
and it was like him revealing yeah
people like magic trick I got you yeah
he's not stupid yeah
like when he does these things cuz
there's a people around him who were
going they getting some traction on this
yeah you know you know how you know we
get this you know let's just put this
out or say this or talk about this right
I just think it's like a listen if I
I've said this on stage before but if
I'm going to like I could campaign to be
a lion tamer at the circus right okay
yeah I could probably be great campaign
hey Montez from workaholics and people
be like I like that dude he was funny in
this and then and then next thing you
know I win I'm the lion tamer at the
circus yeah but you now know you know
what I have to do now I have to be the
lion tamer yeah and I don't know how to
do it yeah yeah yeah I'm saying is I
believe that that's what happened in
this situation I believe here's a guy
that was great in politics he was famous
he's more famous than me he's more
famous than any candidate has ever been
right of course yeah yeah then he got
the job and now he's like oh [ __ ] I
gotta be President the United States I
did a bit in my Netflix special where I
talked about it and I go I don't think
he wanted to win because I say he keeps
saying crazier and crazier [ __ ] hoping
we would not vote for him so he came out
there was there was an interview well no
there was an interview where he goes
Barack Obama is the founder of Isis and
then there was a Republican radio
station who was interviewing him and
they go oh you mean that his policies
helped create Isis he goes no no I'm
saying he's the founder of Isis I was
like this dude is trying to lose and
then I also go on in the special and I
say if you look at the moment he wins
he's shocked because you know you could
actually bring it up on YouTube he keeps
stopping as he's walking to the podium
he's like yeah they've voted for me is
that I gotta do
[ __ ] I know do you know like why would
you want that job his ego he's got an
ego I know but what I'm saying is like
you were loved by rappers and Hollywood
and and you got all this like great
business you could do in Russia by the
way that's what he would he wanted the
reason he hates the press is because he
wants their love the reason he hates all
these celebrities because he wants their
love so this is a guy whose father
didn't really give him love and he wants
his love he wants to be loved by these
people he right now probably in the back
of his mind he's like I gotta be loved
by all these toothless [ __ ] why
can't you know whoever it is a hot
actress why can't I get to her love why
can't jay-z give me a tweet exactly and
listen it is it's ego like that's why
again when you see anything that happens
he makes it about himself he can't help
himself he has got I mean I think he's
got a mental illness in that it's a
theater I think they say like it's so
short a person offices are listen
anybody that is great at anything right
that has been successful at anything got
a little bit of something like that
oh absolutely but what I'm saying is in
degree what I'm saying is cuz you ask
why listen it could have just all been
accidental it could have been like
Howard Stern I've heard talk he's got
the theory that he announced the
president's the run for presidency cuz
he wanted to negotiate his deal for The
Apprentice to get better and that's what
Stern's
thing is so it was all accidental and
just kept going I feel the same way I
believe it I feel like in the middle of
the campaign somebody came to him and
said yo you know you actually doing all
right
I believe it then he was like oh [ __ ]
okay just tried to make it it was like I
think he got to a point where he was
like okay let's see you do it be
presidency but see again this is where
this is where that ego thing comes in
because I think when he when they
grabbed him by the [ __ ] thing came out
there was a lot of talk about from the
Republican side saying there was actual
talk I think I think it was uh what was
that guy's name his original press
secretary and I forget his name right
now but uh whatever the name was
supposedly he was leading the charge of
need to replace Don now with pence
we got a pence is gonna have to be the
running the the the at that point and it
was late in the game but and and by the
way if Donald if Trump did not have an
ego and he really were calculating and
understood what you just said which is
like I've gotten out of it what I needed
I've gotten the publicity I've got the
followers your and go negotiate the [ __ ]
out of my deal they were supposedly
talking to somebody about starting their
own network like he was if he had that
wherewithal he could have pulled out at
that point and been like up got mother
[ __ ] I'm out let this Mike Pence dude
go get his ass kick and I'm just gonna
go run my empire I'm gonna talk [ __ ]
about everybody and nobody can say
anything by the way if he loses this
election like I would not be surprised
if he's like like he takes over Sean
Hannity show oh yeah yeah no there's
definitely a yeah he'll be like on foxed
I guess the thing is like you know and
then he could say whatever he wants
that's the point I mean he already does
but I'm like yeah yeah I mean but that's
my whole point is like he could have
been like you know if he didn't get into
this he could have been like yeah man I
paid a pornstar whatever I was you know
but here's a thing though who cares he
still said that he still said that
you're right yeah what I'm saying is
like we have this idea that the
president is supposed to be some sort of
like you know moral I've gone that's
that's but by the way we're the only
ones that think like that right okay the
French President had his mistress and
his wife oh yeah yeah at a funeral like
my thing was like yeah wait he paid a
hooker to shut up
well that's what yeah well that's when
the whole Bill Clinton thing happened to
like it's like okay that's expected but
it's beyond I mean with this guy he's a
disaster we don't want our lead the
person representing us to be someone
that does that yeah and you know what he
thought so too yeah that's why he paid
the hooker off that's like if that's the
biggest indictment of him of being like
well he shouldn't be the leader right
that's the problem I don't think that
that's I don't think that that is his
like I think that the indictment of him
is like all this damage he's doing like
I just woke up today look at this you
know checking out the muse and it's like
the
now takes another dive because people
don't know what's going on because he
keeps doing this tariff [ __ ] I know like
he's so he's just shooting from the hip
I know but you know he's like had Tony
hitch clip on Hinchcliffe on yeah he was
like you know this what he said about
triamese like Trump's the one of the
most anti-war presidents we've had
definitely in like a 50 60 years but let
me let me just let me now pull that back
for you for a second I agree with you
but his but his National Security
Advisor John Bolton is a super hawk
Pompeyo is a hawk and as someone who's
born in Iran and has watched the Iran
situation closely they painted him into
a corner right now yeah so it's very
possible that something small will
happen and he from the in that water and
the waters there and will have to go to
war so I agree he has been he because he
came in saying I don't want to do war
and as a matter of fact when he said I
want to pull out of Syria I was all for
it going like oh we should pull out of
Syria but then the way he was doing it
and I heard a lot of people talking
about it I go wait a minute this isn't
the most it's like we're out in six
months or whatever he is if he doesn't
really think about it he just says does
he know about no [ __ ] how do you know
about like you running a company in
you're a TV host equivalent to like one
of us
all of a sudden becoming absolutely even
but even more so so when somebody says
like he's stupid it feels like I don't
think he's curious about a lot of stuff
I think he's really good at what he does
he's a good thing he's not stupid I
don't think he just he just doesn't have
all the qualifications my point to you
is be the leader of the free world
exactly that's all absolutely and my
point my point is that like if I were to
win the presidency I would at least be
like hey give me some books give me a
couple of these like experts on these
things and teach me so he doesn't care
about that I disagree with you 100% if I
was running for president I would be
laughing the whole way thinking why am i
running for president and then if I'm
about to win what do I need to learn
more for these people don't care no but
that's my point is so that's the
difference between I think once you
become president like I think that he's
still like he still is like look at this
what I'm good at
so he but I'm good at you got in my lane
yeah you do you
I'm gonna do me yeah then the problem
becomes like I actually have talked to a
few people that are like economists and
I've said is there any kind like who is
giving him advice on this trade war with
China does everybody I hear from his
people to his advisers to Gary Cohen who
was his economic adviser who who quit
because of this [ __ ] I go everyone I
hear goes this is not the way to go
about it yes China screws us over with a
lot of stuff but the way you're doing it
is playing with fire yeah but how else
are you supposed to do it like I'm not
saying he's doing the right thing but
what I'm saying is like like we
shouldn't lay down I don't think we
should lay down it has been laying down
with NATO we've been and laying down
with we've been it's just what we do
we're like you know we can't be the the
sheriffs of the whole world absolutely
but not expect to like get some support
but but what we've done has brought
security to the world in many places and
in many ways and we are right now the
richest country and we've just done what
we've done and it's been it's been 40 50
years of no world war they've been [ __ ]
here and there but no world war but when
you go in and goes like he says he'll
say well you know what we're pulling out
of South Korea and you know I'm trusting
what kim jeong-hoon is saying I'm like
shooting up missiles yeah but you know
what hey you know what though here's the
thing I'm gonna give the dude and his
staff the benefit of the doubt in the
same way that during the first Gulf War
right when the general was on CNN given
fake [ __ ] so the people over there they
thought the death and it was all fake
right yeah you got the president going
like we're gonna do this like no they're
not what's really going on behind closed
doors right that's what's really going
oh I understand what you're saying but
also I think that look you got a look at
people's you know he doesn't have any
history in pollen in politics right but
a guy like John Bolton does John Bolton
I'm surprised he's even got a job he's
one of the reasons we ended up in Iraq
and being in Iraq is one led to the
creation of Isis and that led to a lot
of [ __ ] that went down but he's still
working you gotta look at a guy like
Mike Pompeo who's also a hawk so when it
comes to certain things you got to look
at these people and so when you go to
some of his advisors and you go just
like you said oh this dudes only credit
was that he was a commentator on Fox and
now he's the guy's you know what saying
so German that scares me cuz I don't see
any guys well that's why it's important
to talk about who's going to replace him
absolutely and I just told you I hope
it's Kamala Harris okay or I hope it's
Elizabeth Warren I would love to hear
you know I would love to hear some like
you know some also Jobrani jokes onstage
about you know about these things the
only reason why I say that is because
the more press and even us talking about
him even on the podcast right this yeah
all we're doing is it's just he's just
in space taking space anyways there's
been a great conversation with mister
Maz Jobrani I appreciate you coming on
the podcast and we'll have all of Mazdas
information he has a great podcast of
his own what's a call back to school
with Maz Jobrani I'm happy we had a
chance to talk man yes it's been great
you are the man I enjoyed everything
that we talked about in a politics
religion all the stuff that we talked
about so let's keep that keep that
conversation going and all of his
information will be right there
underneath right there guys if you take
a look and it's a pleasure to have you
on and thanks for listening we're from a
Griffin and I will talk to you guys next
week thank you